هنا وبالادله والقليله مازال اهالي منطقه
السواره غرب منطقه الزوايده في وسط قطاع
غزه يحاولون بايديهم وبادوات بسيطه
التعامل مع اخراج عدد من شهداء المجزره
الاسرائيليه في منطقه السواره وبالتحديد
في منزل عائله ابو مطوي حيث ما زال عدد
كبير من جثث الشهداء متواجد تحت هذه
البنايه التي قصفتها الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه بعده صواريخ خط خطيها
زي ما انت شايف ناس مزارعين وعندهم
اصحابهم ناس نازحين الدور الفوقاني هو
اللي كانوا ساكنين فيه عيلتهم دار ابو
مطوي تم استهدافهم يعني ايش اقوللك شيء
اكبر من صاروخ يعني تقدر تقول قنبله هزت
المكان كله و زي ما انت شايف الدار فيها
يمكن حوالي ما يقارب 40 نفر وفي شهداء
طلعنا منهم في الليله امبارح شهدا وقاعدين
بكمل بندور على بقاياهم يعني هي شايف
الجرافه بتشتغل وهذا هي اللي صار يا عم
[موسيقى]
الحديد تم الاستعانه بعدد من الرافعات هنا
ولكن الدمار الكبير في المنطقه لا يزال
يخيم تم اخراج اطفال لا يتجاوز اعمارهم
ايضا ايام فقط من تحت انقاذ هذه البنايه
التي دمرتها الصواريخ الاسرائيليه سبقت
هذه الغاره ايضا غارات اخرى على المحافظه
الوسطى حيث تكثف الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه من غاراتها على مخيم النصيرات
وصل قطاع غزه او اغارت على منزل لعائله
ايضا النابلسي تم ارتقاء اعداد من الشهداء
وصلوا مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في دير البلاح
اسرائيل لازالت توغل في دم الشعب
الفلسطيني بعد محكمه لهاي كنا متوقعين انه
هذه وطئ الهجوم البري على الشعب الفلسطيني
وقتله وذبحوا انها تخف عنه لكن للاسف
الشديد بنلاقي الامور قاعده بتزداد سوء
وبعدين بيذبحوا ولا زالوا يعني مصرين على
قتله وتشريده ويعني بكفي الهم اللي هو فيه
والبل اللي هو فيه هم لازالوا لازالوا
بيذبحوا فيه وبيدمر فيه و بيخربوا
عليه المواطنون يتحدثون عن ما يقارب من 50
شخص مازال عالقا تحت انقاذ هذه البنايه
وهذا المنزل الذي دمرته الصواريخ
الاسرائيليه بدون سابق انذار هنا والحديث
يدور عن اعداد كبيره جدا وما ت متواجده
تحت انقاذ هذه البنايه التي دمرت الغارات
الاسرائيليه العنيفه على منطقه الزوايده
غرب مدينه دير البلح اشرف ابو عمره لقناه
الجزيره دير البلح وسط قطاع غزه